there's been plenty of coverage of the
thousands of casualties inflicted by
Israel along its border with Gaza but
what's been the role of Hamas in the
bloodshed the organization that runs
Gaza and is labeled a terrorist group by
Western countries my guest this week
here in Beirut is Osama Hamden a senior
member of Hamas is ruling Politburo did
the movement deliberately provoke Israel
with no thought at all for the safety of
its citizens
[Music]
ossama Hamden welcome to conflict zone
thank you more than a hundred people
dead
thousands injured on the Israeli border
with Gaza this what you wanted of course
not
you knew this would happen and yet you
encouraged people to go there well it
was not expected to be like this we are
talking about more than one four hundred
forty people were killed more than seven
thousand people who were injured it was
a civilian protest it was an armed
protest the the people who were killed
women children all people all what they
wanted is to go home back they want to
return to their homeland but you
deliberately encouraged people to put
themselves in harm's way harm's way on
April the six your leader in the Gaza
Strip
yah-ha as sin were made it quite clear
that Hamas had violent intentions he
told people we will uproot the borders
we will pluck out their hearts and we
will pray in Jerusalem is that a
peaceful message work out their hearts
for for the Palestinians it's completely
a peaceful message to go to brain and
al-aqsa mosque to take back their
occupied lands to leave the borders and
we will pluck out their no that's
peaceful no no he didn't say that he is
talking about the army he is talking
about the army who's killing the
Palestinians every day he's talking
about he talked about his way is talking
no he's talking about the army who was
killing the Palestinians every day he is
talking about the army who killed just
in the last through eight weeks
more than 140 Palestinians injured more
than 7,000 Palestinians he killed the
Medical Teams he killed everyone this
was a message this wasn't waiting no
totally it wasn't a message balance it
was a clear message from the Palestinian
nation that we want our rights back what
is Donald Trump doing is not helping
he is destroying the future of the
Palestinian wanting my lunch not the boy
is not in China he is not helping the
Israelis either and we don't like any
kind of blood in the scene if you don't
I was able to go home back what were
your militants doing 50 of them they
were not no no you have to differentiate
between two things
some are Albert the wheel yes he said
that he says 50 militants had known
killed
he didn't say militants he said 50
members of Hamas and you know that Hamas
is a big movement there is a militant
wing in Hamas but the people who were
marching they were civilians there were
students they were teachers they were
yes you use and chose me you know at all
not the 50 Palestinians who were killed
from Hamas they were not militant and as
is news that resin and a jar was not a
militant she was an else and she was
helping the injured people when she was
shot in the back the children who were
killed they were our children we are not
using the people we are asking for the
rise of the Palestine but what the UN
said the UN had no doubt that that's
what you were doing the special
coordinator for the Middle East peace
process warned you in no uncertain terms
not to use the protest as a cover to
attempt to place bombs at the fence and
create provocations with mass how much
operatives he said must not hide among
the demonstrations did not happen no one
would bombs no militants hide among the
people all the killed people were
civilians I dare anyone to say that
there was one militant through the
people they were all civilians they were
from Hamas Sveta Popular Front Islamic
al-jihad
normal people who support the people who
are working that wasn't the Egyptian
view this is why it was any Egyptian no
it was also no it wasn't because Israel
says Egypt has evidence that you funded
clashes along the board
and the Egyptians warned you that if the
violence went on they would not help you
I will I will not accept the Israeli
story about what the Egyptians have said
because we talk directly to the
Egyptians the Egyptians didn't tell a
story no no the Egyptian era the
Egyptians are talking directly to us
they are not in the position that
Israelis as well yes so directly to the
Israel exactly for both sides so we
don't need to hear from the Israelis
about the Egyptians we are hearing
directly from the Egyptians they have
their own people inside Gaza and they
understand that it was a peaceful
civilian Marsh it was not militant
they've said this clearly you don't have
to give the Israelis any reasons to kill
your people that was their advice and
was a true advice the x-rays are lying
did not give any evidence the evidence
mr. Hamden is that this was not peaceful
on April the 27th the New York Times
reported an incursion involving dozens
of people who made it through a barbed
wire barrier some of them throwing
firebombs other Rowling's burnings tower
tires people armed with pistols another
of your leaders Mahmoud oz aha
you know him well he even boasted in a
television interview that the
demonstrations had been boasted by Hamas
weapons no he didn't say that he did
using the the tires burning that here in
order to protect the civilians from the
bullets of the Israeli snipers by
burning those tires you don't allow the
Israeli snipers to shoot your people so
it wasn't a militant action it was a
protection action for the Palestinians
you didn't differently your
representative or Ismail radwan your
representative is Marwan said on April
the 27th to the people encouraging them
to put themselves in harm's way when we
are brave we are getting close to
martyrdom martyrdom martyrdom you wanted
them to go and be killed and in your
view become martyrs no this wasn't he
was it encouraged me he was saying yes
themselves
no he was saying that while he was there
he wasn't saying that while he was
sitting in his home or house
he was or office he was saying there
doesn't matter where he was we know it's
us more than he is a leader and he was
with home with his own people that means
he's working for the benefit of the
Palestinians it's an occupation this is
the point don't talk about the
Palestinians talk about the occupation
the Israelis are occupying our lands
they are killing our people the United
States is providing them with Reubens no
one is helping the Palestinians at the
end of the day Donald Trump is telling
the Palestinians you don't have a
capital excuse me Jerusalem is not yours
it's not for the Christians even it's
for the Israelis you don't have an
option of a Palestinian he didn't say
that he said that but he said that he
said that they are not know he said
cluding no no he said unfortunate he
said Jerusalem Andrey's excuse me
yes no he said Jerusalem is the capital
of the Jewish people he didn't say
Jerusalem is a Palestine and said he's
not talking about the capital issues
will be he did a big mistake by saying
it's a capital for a Jewish people this
is wrong there was nothing like that in
the history it was built by the Arabs
they can an astable this city and they
can honest they they provide peace for
everyone who lived in you a chance you
said this I know and we have two points
our duty is to resist the occupation yes
that means we need support you don't
have none don't not the contamination of
some people you X we have that dust my
you they pressed no regret for the loss
of life on the contrary you welcomed it
because you think these people became
martyrs and you're happy that they did
do you know the casualties a lot of
things that we are happy of losing our
boys children girls
daughters wives I wonder we are I want
to do this but the Israelis who are
responsible for that last night last
night
in the General Assembly of the UN all
the people voted for the Palestinian Huy
120 countries 120 countries for this or
your the support of the Palestinians not
you even turn down you refuse to accept
a medical shipment from the Israeli
military despite a severe shortage of
medicines in the hospitals in Gaza and
your Hamas spokesman has a chasm said
the occupation is trying to show that it
has a human face which is wrong these
trucks carrying these medical supplies
are covered with Palestinian blood you
didn't even want vital medicines to help
save the lives of your injured people we
have you we have the medicine from Egypt
we have the medicine from Arab countries
like Morocco didn't have enough we have
the medicine but we can't accept someone
to shoot us in our heads and now our
chests and then claim that he is trying
to provide us with medical support this
is which he was no he was trying to
provide you Israel was trying they
provide you medical secrecy
this is hypocrisy they are hypocrites he
means to save life when you know you
know they did not want to people that's
a matter of money if he want to survive
if you want to save life he has to
withdraw from the occupied lands if he
want to save life he has not to issue
orders to shoot the civilians this is
how you save lives not by killing them
and then claim that you want to send
someone to open graves for the killed
people or to put some medicine on the
ones which you have done mr. Honda the
net result of your actions and your
protests demonstrations piles of dead
bodies young people who have terrible
injuries suffering terrible pain
disfigured and disabled for life if you
had hoped that the violence on the
border would get you good headlines and
Israel bad headlines you failed didn't
you no we didn't in fact I will remind
you fail the first and the Father it was
the same scene the First Intifada
what force decides to sit on the table
and negotiate the second and the father
four days rate to accept that withdrawal
from des des I remind you of that the
people they received the message from
the Israelis nothing is easy you have to
resist ten years you have ten years of
Namas Raeleen user you have to see this
nothing this is nothing Co P this is the
outcome from the Israeli behavior
against the Palestinians you have to
resist without resistance you can't have
anything if you are in the jail you are
in the city you are studying in the
school or the university you have to
resist this no it's not slow its it's
like it's not slow
yeah sn1 yeah Hassan wha your man in the
Gaza Strip Hamas Hamas leader in Gaza he
said last month he's not looking for a
confrontation with Israel but at the
same time he tells journalists if there
is one Hamas will crush Israel come on
be honest there's no way Hamas can
crushes why don't you tell the truth
well giving people meaningless slogans
why don't they just a slogan he didn't
say that I did say no this is a poster
foreign journalists it said that I know
what he said he said we don't want to
fight but if they forced us to fight we
will do what we have to do he said that
if someone attacks you you will protect
yourself you would defend yourself even
though you believe that is more stronger
than you
we can't surrender we will not sin and
the Palestinian people will not
surrender only Hamas all the Persian
palace your policy is bankrupting Gaza
your economy is shot to hell
you have whose happen you have all you
have employment who is 43% what was
responsible for that you may in part you
the partition the partition is
responsible for that poverty has gone up
from 30% in 2011 to 50% the situation
under your rule the situation must Bank
the situation Jerusalem is not better
than this the problem the main problem
occupation don't try to say that there
is other problem the main problem
occupation let the occupation live and
you will see how the Palestinian so very
well to blame other people but no but
your policy we always led to this
problem we are no no no all you have to
do is put down your arms what we are
supposed to and you would get investment
investment you've been promised
investment no we were um the Americans
have told you a funding is available for
project otherwise our Gaza will collapse
yes yes they will not collapse the
Israelis are destroying the Palestinians
life everyday not only in Gaza in West
Bank and in Jerusalem so don't say that
the Palestinians are the blame the blame
are the Israelis who are the side you
have to blame they are the occupation
the international community considered
them as an occupation ask the
international community and those eyes
why they are not withdrawn from the
occupied lands you refuse to put the
health and welfare of your people ahead
of a so-called resistance strategy that
has brought your people nothing the UN
says to you the key to unlocking the
economic projects that could make a
difference to your people is that the
2014 ceasefire is observed and that all
factions in Gaza refrain from illicit
arms build-up and violence on the ground
but you won't do that will you
well we know we were here that we kept
that better than the Israelis the one
who attacks the one who's shooting the
one who's killing the one who's putting
this under the siege is Desiree Ellis so
we told the UN that we are ready to deal
with that but till now there is no
answer from that is it not only do you
not get on with the Israelis you can't
get on with the Palestinians in the West
Bank I know all your attempts all your
attempts to unify have failed haven't
been year after year unfortunately for
this but we will continue but you mean
unfortunately it's a big deal we are
unfortunately that we feel will failed
but we are working and we will continue
our work to unify the people you face
because you can't put aside your narrow
no action you know for the good of the
palace that's not true a few days ago
there was a
isten west bank the one who prevented
the people to protest against occupation
was Mahmoud Abbas it wasn't Hamas the
people who moved they were not Hamas
members they were they were from Popular
Front and some other left-wing
organizations and NGOs he he he
prevented them yesterday his bullies
attacks them like the Israelis have done
and what happens when the the
Palestinian goes was those two it was
exactly
I was I was attempt no fascination
this is a good question our
investigations clarified that the one
who was in charge for this assassination
trial was an official officer in the
palace Takata doesn't believe you no
they don't believe you okay we have
evidences we show the people the
Egyptians were following up the
investigation
and they were totally shocked by what
has happened we know the names of the
officials who did that we gave those
names to Mahmoud Abbas and he's supposed
to make an action because this was the
prime minister but he did not make any
Palestinian Authority says the more
Hamas tries to evade responsibility the
deeper it sinks that's their verdict on
your well explanations if it was a good
thing he's in the worst situation
he can't move without an Israeli secures
so I I don't do I will not take at
nanometre says because everyone have
make jokes when they say when they hear
and listen tot none about me I don't I
mean it doesn't know anything the one
who knows that no one who knows the fact
is Majid Farraj Majid Faraj just a
moment about after the explosion he said
all right you what extract your verse he
said that's you about my version he said
clearly in the front of all the
journalists it was two bombs
we shook the blaze it was two bombs but
one exploded the other did not know he
knows it doesn't believe you let's talk
them I'm done let's talk about human
rights because you've been widely
criticized for many years by
international
as well as those based in the
Palestinian territories and this isn't
something to do with the Israelis this
is your bank year between January the
1st and 31st of October last year the
Independent Commission for Human Rights
in Palestine received a hundred and
ninety three complaints of torture and
ill-treatment by your security forces
why do you go on doing this why do you
go on mistreating your people you claim
well you came to worry about their
health and their security but you
torture them at home we do not do that
the situation is clear in Gaza he came
at each time and he investigated and he
asked and the people answered him and
the police answered him and most of
those claims were not true the most of
those claims they weren't true to those
claims where they're well they're well
documented as you know particularly your
attacks on journalists let's go through
some examples because you love to deny
12 last year police in Gaza attacked a
photographer working for Agence
france-presse his name muhammad abdul
razzaq al baba 47 years old he was
beaten up while covering a demonstration
at the Jabalia refugee camp he was hit
with a stick over his eye he needed
hospital treatment an interior ministry
official later apologized why did that
beat not and why was he done those those
police who did that they were punished
and they really how much punishment they
were taken to the court and they were
jailed because they have how long did
they get you don't know no no I know
exactly they were late for one year for
what they have really so they were
punished and and there was a
compensation for him from the ministry
it didn't stop or change the same thing
happened if some accidents took place
here or there that doesn't mean that we
say it nothing is happy it's not here
it's a year it's clear that our position
if something wrong was done we say we
are sorry we punish the people who did
that and our people trusted that so they
talk they don't keep silent they talk
they talk to
cause they trust that they will have
their right back
January 14th police arrested a camera
man from the national video agency
Guevara they were interrogated and they
were beaten up they were planning to
cover a protest demonstration they were
only released after signing a pledge not
to report on any events in Gaza against
Hamas this was clear intimidation clear
travel talk you will talk about the
various beatings you will talk about
those details you have to talk the spoke
man of them is with the spokesman of the
Ministry of Interior what you know I'm
telling you the general idea we don't
accept anything of that we are punishing
the people who are doing this because we
don't accept that to happen if someone
did that he will be punished today
yesterday or tomorrow this is a
community with two million people
accidents happened and we solve the
problems and we punish the people who
are making mistakes just a month we a
gun degree of anything about this we
don't support this we don't even say
good words about just a month ago the
human rights group al haq reported the
two forces had arrested one of the
program directors at the nasarah
refugee camp which is overseen by the UN
she is sama Abu Guyot arrested by your
internal security on May the 9th without
any warrant or without any charges in
violation of her constitutionally eyes
she's been held fifty days after she was
detained she still had not been able to
see her husband well I will hurt you I
want to tell you the story she was not
arrested they sent here from they just
kept her son they sent here they sent
her a request from the DA office she
went by herself and there she was told
about that she shoesies against her and
she wasn't according to the law she has
not been allowed to have a lawyer court
she has been prevented from seeing there
were there was a lawyer and everything
was done with her according to the law
that's not what Al Haqq says well they
said that this is part of the propaganda
we know some propaganda
so you know how they do this because
they want to make pressure this is the
right they can do that who deny this is
the way you do this no I got old test I
give you faggus me you just didn't they
they did not introduce the complete
facts she was asked but by the DA office
to come by herself she come by herself
she was told that you are responsible
for this and that and we want according
to law to hold you for 15 days this is
the Palestinian law this is not Hamas
law when is she going to be released
this is the Palestinian law and she will
she will face the judge and he will
release her if she was innocent and if
there was charges he will tell her the
charges not Hamas not the police the DA
office and the judicial system
I just want a final point you have a
goal an independent Palestinian state on
the 67 borders with Jerusalem as your
capital I ask you if this is what your
state would look like arbitrary arrests
without due process journalists shot in
the leg for carrying out their
legitimate work threats and beatings is
this what you're staying what you are is
what your state would what you are
saying is not slightly documenting not
okay what you are saying is totally not
fair everyone knows that we provide
security in Gaza
unlike the situation before 2006
everyone knows that everyone knows that
the judicial system is working as the
best way better than in ramallah or
other places everyone knows that we are
trying to protect our people if you have
an element that the state it will be a
democratic state there will be elections
it will be a state build as a new state
on the best level decide if you lose the
elections
you totally yes two years yes you'd only
get 30 percent of the vote understanding
over two guesses okay the last time you
get 30 percent even if we get 10 percent
we will accept that when you decide to
choose democracy you have to respect the
results
if you win or if you lose this is our
internal decision before participating
in the elections 2005 we said we want to
participate regardless to the results
this time or next time or the time after
that we we will respect that we are we
are respecting that internally all right
we are the movement against by
Democratic way to point Assam I'm done
thanks very much for being on country
[Music]